on Australia's East Coast smoke has
descended like fog wildfires have
triggered a state of emergency in both
New South Wales and Queensland
threatening hundreds of thousands of
people and homes in crammed batch Jason
Tyler nervously watch his smoke billow
over the ridge his family has been
sheltering here for three days
after flames forced them to abandon
their house and run for their lives I've
been in a cyclone before it came through
like a cyclone the wind
it just blew everything almost 90
degrees things haven't blown off the
table and it was just get out straight
away get out there car boot now contains
everything they could salvage there's
got the absolute bare essentials for us
oh wow but this beautful is all you've
managed to save at the moment at the
moment yeah it's all good but they're
still not safe the fire is coming this
way
he and his kids are ready to flee again
there's no doubt this was to come the
winds are going to pick up all the
predictions on the on the weather at the
moment are saying that the winds are
going to get worse and it really comes
down to the direction of the wind
firefighters are stationed on roads
ready to raise the alarm if new towns
need to evacuate Chris Holman has been
battling bush fires for more than 20
years but even he's never seen anything
on this scale whichever way the wind
blows that's the way the fire goes it's
that big you can't really do anything
until it comes out on dopa country then
you can light it or do property
protection but as far as stopping that
up in there more than half the fires in
New South Wales are now uncontained and
soaring temperatures and strong winds
worsening conditions the smoke you can
see on the horizon is from a fire that's
burning at Hill Ville and it's been
burning out of control for two days now
it's one of a number in this area but
we're being told that a change in wind
is now pushing it towards more people
more homes and if you just have a look
at the ground here it's bone-dry it's
like a tinderbox one spark and it all
goes up for the first time ever
Australia's biggest city Sydney is on
high alert for catastrophic damage with
warnings worse could still be to come
Siobhan Robbins Sky News New South Wales
Australia